what's up guys I'm Ryan right I got to
bed super [ __ ] I'm talking like 5:00
in the morning status woke up to go to
the bathroom check the comments got
blown up with comments about Star Wars
Episode 7 the force awakens official
Japanese trailer and I was like [ __ ]
sleep let's watch this [ __ ] wow why
I know
we're someone alright
[Music]
where you come from I know all about
waiting for my family
[Music]
I will fulfill our yesterday I'm
finished
what you started
[Music]
I don't know the name
[Music]
there were stories about what happened
force
true
[Music]
yeah we get you
[Music]
pop is not last today it is found
they can read Japanese it says the force
awakens
[Music]
dude I am NOT going back to sleep
settle awesome I really like what
they're doing with Maury I think
what's-her-name I like how it's
promoting her as the lead of this story
it's cool to see that they're putting a
female character upfront for the Star
Wars film she is the star of the new
Star Wars movie she seems like the main
protagonist I'm onboard for that I mean
she seems like a wonderful actress and I
think my girlfriend's asleep in the
other room but holy [ __ ] she beautiful
[Music]
something about this trailer kind of
makes me feel like you could call this
Star Wars a new hope part two you really
get an episode four vibe from this
trailer there's been a lot of
speculation that the villain Naga kylo
Ren kylo Ren if I don't pronounce it
only read it they think Luke Skywalker
is actually the bad guy that they're
gonna do some big reveal that's why they
haven't shown him in the trailers I
think that's a reasonable theory I don't
think that's how it's gonna go down I
think what JJ Abrams is doing is he
wants us to believe that that's what's
gonna happen it's like yeah they cast a
guy named Adam driver to play kylo Ren
but you know like James Earl Jones did
the voice of Darth Vader but they had a
different actor when they revealed his
face and returned to the Jedi maybe
they'll do like a similar thing I don't
know
I'm hoping that's not the twist because
so many people have speculated about it
already I'm hoping we get a nicer
surprise than that but still I mean it
would be kind of cool to see Luke on the
dark side and the other thing that I
feel like this trailers trying to
mislead us into is Finn becoming the new
Jedi I feel like then yeah he will wheel
the lightsaber at one point maybe he
survives the fight I feel like the theme
of this is about the force and the power
of the force and you know all that stuff
about belief and energy everything that
comes down to being in tune
with the force that's what could cause
you to really conquer and I'm thinking
that Rey will be the one who is actually
the real Jedi I mean they're really
promoting her like female Luke Skywalker
in this there were a couple of shots
that I really loved when Chewbacca blows
up that part of the ship I don't know if
that's like a trailer just using a
different cut like a will just show
Chewie press a button and then we'll use
a different scene to make it look like
that it kind of looks like Chewie
detonated himself like he's did a
suicide attack which would be [ __ ] up
come on Chewie don't do that Chewbacca
we need you man we played it forever for
you to come back and now you're just
gonna kill yourself
[ __ ] hairy [ __ ] I have a hairy ass
only you know what I mean of course you
know what I mean it's pretty literal
Sean kylo Ren puts his lightsaber up
against Rey and she's like terrified by
it the acting in this looks [ __ ] epic
this scale of this the stakes look so
[ __ ] high I'm excited to see a movie
that's gonna blend omage with complete
originality I feel like JJ Abrams will
be great at doing that well people are
speculating about whether or not Finn
will lose that battle whether or not
Finn dies what a lot of people are
seeing is like no Finn can't die because
he's already signed on for Episode eight
it's already been confirmed if you look
at what happened with obi-wan Kenobi he
died in Episode four in case you guys
haven't seen it giving you a little
spoiler he gets killed in Episode four
but he does come back in Empire Strikes
Back he wasn't alive in Empire Strikes
Back but he was back so maybe they'll do
a similar thing I'm not sure I think the
one that I really liked was hope is not
lost today it is found gets me thinking
like are they talking about Rey is that
them talking about Luke Skywalker does
Luke Skywalker equal hope a lot of great
questions are coming to mind and a lot
of great speculation I can't wait till
December 18th already got my tickets so
yeah keep a lookout for that review
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe today by clicking this button
and become a reject I'd die I was trying
to combine Jedi with reject and I came
out with tie-dye it's actually a sex
position
and summers yo you guys are the best you
make me laugh so much thank you
Aaron summers I'm glad we can make you
laugh making you laugh has been the
biggest obstacle in my life I know you
struggled with depression I know you
also struggle with a wreck tile
dysfunction so having both of those
conditions combined with the fact that
you also have constipation I know that
laughing is the best medicine for you
not actually getting the prescriptions
that your doctor recommends for you not
following through with their procedures
not following through what your
therapist tells you to do but laughing
at our stupid jokes
keep it up it's the best way to
happiness